paglin and ac thompson detailed the
cia's practice of sending suspected
terrorists to countries where the
authors argue they're kept in secret
prisons and subjected to torture they
spoke about it recently at city lights
bookstore in san francisco for an hour
15 minutes
you're gonna be on tv so you have to
have a copy of the book on the table
with you otherwise it's no good at all
no one will notice what the book looks
like on the shelves and no one will buy
it so we had to do that right then
well thank you guys so much for coming
um he's trevor
i'm trevor
um
i guess our story starts in the desert
and it starts in 2002 in the desert that
it starts in is not afghanistan it's not
iraq
it's not egypt it's not one of these
places that we traditionally associate
with the war on terror
this desert in fact was in nevada
somewhat peculiar airstrip in nevada
which is called
um the desert rock airstrip
the desert rock airstrip is the airstrip
for the nevada test site which is of
course the
nuclear proving grounds for the united
states
and uh this is a kind of a peculiar
airport because
who's going to who flies in the nevada
test site while the department of energy
flies in the nevada test site
kind of strange people fly to the
department um to the desert rock
airstrip
and there's a group of people who pay
attention to what kinds of aircraft fly
to the desert rock airstrip uh people we
call them plane spotters who sort of pay
attention to strange aviation activity
and
in december of 2002 one of these uh
plane spotters who happens to be an air
traffic controller as his day job
reported something relatively unusual
onto a listserv
[Music]
december 2002 is very interesting based
on aircraft with the destination of
desert rock
n8183j a c-130 widely thought to be used
by the cia arrived from washington
dulles
a couple of days later
n313p a boeing business jet arrived it
is also it is often used on government
contracts visiting lots of exotic places
eg libya
also arriving was n85 vm a gulf stream
four
both arrived from andrews air force base
cessna 208 and for 403 vp also around
this was an unusual cast of aircraft
indeed
this one this aircraft was owned by a
company called one leasing which uh
in the words of the plane spotters was
an investigative dead end they couldn't
figure out what this company was
this
aircraft was also very interesting to
them uh they also realized that this was
probably a cia aircraft
it was operated by a company called
tepper aviation out of florida and
tepper aviation had been in the news in
the late 1980s when one of its planes
had crashed in angola
this plane itself was actually bought
by what looks like the cia from the
government of zaire uh with a guy named
kamir palavi as a middle man uh that
name might sound familiar if it does
it's because he's the shah of iran's
nephew nh5vm was a very unusual
gulfstream this was owned by one of the
co-owners of the boston red sox
and it is usually used to
you know ferry around baseball players
and that sort of thing very unusual that
it was coming from andrews air force
base to the desert rock airstrip
and this plane was
n313p this business jet that one of
these plane spotters mentioned owned by
a company called premier executive
transport services which also seemed to
be an investigative dead end
the plane spotters began tracking these
aircraft
the the aircraft had called attention to
themselves by
behaving unusually and so they uh
the people that pay attention to these
airplanes started getting their flight
logs from the federal aviation
administration and following them around
where they might fly
again they started to see some rather
unusual things
as one of the plane spotters put it on
who we interviewed for the book he said
when i saw these things flying to
guantanamo bay that's when i knew they
were the real thing
it turns out that these aircraft
would become famous as the so-called
torture planes these were the planes
that would turn out the cia was using
for its extraordinary rendition program
and there were other planes as well
now
at that time
none of this was really known it was
just these unusual airplanes showed up
people started tracking them seeing them
go to guantanamo bay something quite
mysterious was going on and this was
basically a small network of aviation
enthusiasts who were pretty obsessive
about
tracking sort of the minutiae and
esoteric information about planes and it
was their little world that this
discussion was going on in right right
what was going on behind the scenes
was of course the beginning of the
so-called war on terror right after 9 11
you have george bush running around
saying things like i don't care what the
international lawyers think i want to
kick some ass you have this other man ko
for black the head of the cia's counter
terrorist center saying that we're going
to find the guys that did this we're
going to put their heads on sticks
they're going to have flies on their
eyeballs when we're done with them
and george tenet
played his politics quite well after 9
11 he realized that there was going to
be some kind of war and that if he
played his cards right the cia would be
put in charge of that war
about six days after 9 11 he went to
bush with a proposal this proposal would
grant the cia vast new powers in the war
on terror
bush signed it on september 17th
we actually still have no idea
what these new powers consisted of but
we have some ideas
now
the other thing that was happening was
that
people like alberto gonzalez and jay
bybee and my colleague at uc berkeley
john you were trying to figure out what
to do with prisoners that would be
captured in this war on terror would
they be treated as soldiers would they
be treated as civilians what rules would
gover the way govern the way that the
united states handled them
the solution that they came up with was
that
the prisoners would neither be
considered soldiers nor would they be
considered civilians this uh they
created this
category of any enemy combatants which
meant that any prisoners captured in
this war on terror would be held outside
of international legal conventions
another thing started happening almost
immediately and that is that people
started disappearing from around the
world
on october 23rd 2001 a guy named jamil
muhammad was kidnapped in pakistan and
was probably taken to jordan
even sheikh al-liby was kidnapped in
pakistan and shipped to an egyptian
torture chamber in november of that year
december abu fazal and abdul aziz also
disappeared from pakistan december 18th
ahmed agiza and muhammad zeri are
kidnapped in sweden and brought to egypt
january 11th muhammad madni grabbed in
jakarta and brought to egypt there are
probably many many more of these the
names that we have are largely due to
mistakes or leaks or something didn't go
exactly right and their name slipped out
so the names that we have probably
represent just the tip of the iceberg
now it turns out that the kinds of
skills that these plane spotters have
this subculture of aviation enthusiasts
it turns out that they would become
quite valuable to
trying to uncover
what happened to these people where they
might have been taken and the reason for
that is that this is a highly
covert program there's very very little
information about it nobody will talk
about it and these airplanes which were
eventually linked to this program became
one of the few threads that you could
pull on to start to unravel what was
going on here and the reason for that is
that there's a real contradiction in the
way that these aircraft are set up and
the contradiction is that the cia is a
civilian agency it's not a
and an arm of the department of defense
um it's not intended to be an arm of the
department of defense
one of the consequences of that is that
the cia
does a lot of their work through front
companies we all know about front
companies and these aircraft are set up
by a bunch of fun companies
and it turns out that even if you're the
cia you're going to set up a fleet of
airplanes you want to be able to
look like civilians you want to be able
to behave like civilians when you want
to and one of the consequences of that
is that you have to file a lot of the
kinds of paperwork that civilian
aviation companies have to file
in order to do their business and for
very good reasons
and for other very good reasons this is
a these these files are public you can
write to the federal aviation
administration get a tremendous amount
of information on any civilian-owned
aircraft that you want
so we started collecting these
registration documents maintenance
records from the airplanes and i'll hand
it over to ac to talk about what we
found and this is sort of where we
started collaborating on this project
and really where the book
was born trevor had been
studying sort of aircraft movements and
had been geeking out about aircraft for
a long time because as part of his
research at cal berkeley he's studying
military secrecy and secret military
installations and planes fly in and out
of those places but for me
as an investigative reporter one of the
things i had been doing for years was
corporate research so
one day in uh last december trevor came
over to my office
and said hey if i wanted to figure out
who owned these planes i wanted to do
some background on them how could we do
that and um we went into a high-end
computer database
at that moment and started pulling up
these registration documents
and so what happens
when you start looking at the people who
own the planes that the cia is using is
you start realizing that these are
companies that exist they exist
in file cabinets and desk drawers but
they don't actually exist
and what we would do is
get together the faa documents we would
get together the
um
corporate registration documents that
any business has to file with
secretaries of state in any state to
operate and we would do stuff like like
this uh slide here where we would pull
three years of records and look at them
and find that well supposedly the
president of the company was a guy named
uh tyler edward tate
but every single time he signed the
corporate registration documents each
year he seemed to have a completely
different signature
and that to us started signifying that
we were in fact looking as we suspected
at cia front companies and not
legitimate companies because when we
sign documents it looks pretty much the
same every time
we also
looked into these companies like premier
executive transport services
like crawl aviation
uh like
one leasing and what we're finding
looking at these companies is that
none of them had executives that we
could actually prove the existence of
the
executives uh didn't own real estate and
most wealthy business owners tend to own
houses that they live in they didn't
have phone numbers we could find they
didn't have um real addresses that their
businesses were operating out of and
when you would put their numbers are
their names into
high-end computer databases
they
wouldn't pop up and you know at this
point you can pretty much locate just
about anyone
but what would pop up
is sort of
these
small
lawyers offices in various places like
this happens to be dead of massachusetts
and this is the law office of hill and
plagueis
and we would find
oh
the only addresses we can find for these
companies that seem to be legitimate and
the only real people that we can find
associated with them are the lawyers who
actually did the physical creep the
creation of creating the companies
meaning they filled out the paperwork
and filed it with the state
with all these phony signatures on it
and uh the only people that we could
find that were actually real were these
attorneys like
dean plakius who's the guy who set up
premier executive transport
or like this slide this is um the people
who set up keeler and tape management
which is a company that supposedly
operates out of reno nevada
that uh
supposedly owns a 737
uh business jet the boeing business jet
and uh in fact the office is simply the
law office
of two family lawyers named
uh stephen and frank peterson and also
the they share an office with a guy
named peter laxall
and this was another place where our
story started this is one of the first
places that we went
uh we wanted to talk to
whoever was behind premier executive
we were pretty sure that they were uh
involved in this rendition thing we were
pretty sure that they were giving cover
to the cia
but we couldn't figure out what the
connection was we couldn't figure out
okay why would this peterson and
peterson folks why would they get
involved
with the cia and we did all this
backgrounding and research trying to
figure out well stephen peterson does he
have any cia connection does he have any
military connection
couldn't figure it out but when we went
to the offices in reno of these folks we
we went in there and we said
hey uh to the secretary
um you know the ac the aclu is suing
your law firm saying that you're
involved with the cia you're giving the
cia cover and you're helping them go
around the world and torture people
you know we thought this is like a
pretty nutty thing to say to somebody
you know and like usually when you say
something like that the people tell you
that you're on drugs and you should get
out of there but it's interesting the
secretary didn't seem very surprised by
this at all and she just very calmly
asked us to leave
um
the thing we noticed when we were there
is
oh this is also the the office the suite
number of a guy named peter laxalt and
something called the paul laxalt group
west
well
that was possibly the connection paul
laxalt was a u.s senator governor of
nevada
arts conservative and very good friend
of uh former cia chief william colby and
also of ronald reagan and we said hey if
there's any possible connection here
through a person to the cia it would
probably be this laxalt guy
and the interesting thing was
when we called paul laxalt's office in
dc and we said hey
um you know we just visited your your
nevada office and we were interested in
this whole cia thing you know what's
going on with that uh his staffer said
we don't have an office in nevada and we
said oh really that's interesting
because your name's on the door a couple
different times and you're on the the
register of people that are in the
building and he said no no we don't have
an office um
so the next time trevor visited the uh
building what happened the name wasn't
there anymore uh however uh the laxalts
were describing us as conspiracy
theorists in the in the local papers now
what was interesting about that to us is
we had suggested they might be connected
to horrible human rights abuses
and all they were doing was
saying that we were conspiracy wing nuts
in the press they weren't suing us they
weren't demanding a retraction and they
weren't saying that we got anything
wrong
uh you know normally when you get
something wrong something serious like
calling someone a accomplice to torture
they want you to correct that so we
thought that was significant that they
didn't
want to talk about arrow
so the trail
from
the lag salts in nevada
led us to
rural north carolina because
while the keeler and tape management
company that operated out of this law
firm office and didn't really have any
uh any real existence
they operated out of there they owned
this plane but the plane was actually
flown by a company in rural north
carolina called aero contractors
and aero contractors we found out was a
fascinating fascinating operation it had
been founded by a guy who was a very
famous cia pilot named jim ryan and jim
ryan was
a pilot in the
vietnam war era in laos he was a
legendary figure in the air america
secret cia operation
and as we researched arrow contractors
we got in touch with someone who had
worked with ryan and had flown for aero
contractors and he laid it out for us he
said
uh the cia had asked jim ryan after air
america's cover had been blown in the
late 70s and it was shut down to start a
new
um aviation firm for the central
intelligence agency and this one would
be a little bit different the cia would
provide it with contracts the cia would
provide it with all kinds of work and
the aero pilots would fly cia pi
fly cia agents around and help them do
missions but it wouldn't be completely
controlled by the c i a work this guy
ryan who was very close to cia and had
just retired he would be running it
and they said and jim could you find
someplace that's kind of nondescript and
within three hours flying time of of
washington dc for us
so ryan was a southerner so he got in
his car and drove from langley south and
um
chose a small airstrip in johnston
county north carolina to start aero
contractors
now
as
the 70s the late 70s and the 80s were
going on they did the things that you do
in the 70s and 80s so they did stuff
like they tried to get back the weapons
that we had given to the mujahideen in
afghanistan that was one of their
missions they did uh work on
narcotics and um
leftist guerrillas in
in uh
south america
in the 80s and early 90s
and then
things started changing with the war on
terrorism and according to our source
who's a former pilot all kinds of money
started flowing into the aero
contractors
uh
basically into their business and they
hired tons of new pilots bought new
planes and were constantly flying around
the world allegedly doing uh rendition
flights and from all the evidence that
looks pretty clear
so the
first thing that we found out that was
kind of startling to us is that we knew
that this war on terror was going on we
knew that these extraordinary renditions
were going on
but
we didn't realize the extent to which it
was going on here as well as it was
going on somewhere else when we think
about renditions and torture and wars
and that sort of thing we have a
tendency to think of it as some place
something that happens somewhere else
that happens in afghanistan or happens
in iraq or happens at guantanamo bay but
what we really found was that the whole
infrastructure that
made this happen was very much a part of
everyday life and looked as banal as any
office building on the street and that
there were indeed many many people
around us hidden in plain sight who were
contributing in one way or another to
all of this
the other part one of the uh
talking about this contradiction between
uh being a civilian agency you know the
cia and having to file these uh flight
plans and that sort of thing
the other avenue that we pursu pursued
is looking at the actual flight plans of
the aircraft not you know first we
looked at where they were registered who
was operating them who was maintaining
them then we started looking at where do
they go
and we started to find
a network that spread
all over the world
all kinds of connections between bizarre
places that uh you we would not normally
think about very much but one of the
consistent themes that came up
was kabul kabul afghanistan
and this as um some people started
getting out of the extraordinary
rendition program there were many many
stories about people
who described being kidnapped and taken
to afghanistan and held in secret
prisons in afghanistan these are places
that are called black sites
and so we
booked a plane ticket to afghanistan to
see if we might be able to find some of
these black sites or talk to people who
had been in there or to get a sense of
what was going on there because it
seemed so crucial to the way that the
whole war on terror was working even
though the war in iraq had already begun
and a lot of people had forgotten about
afghanistan it seemed to still play a
very major role behind the scenes
when we got there one of the first
things that we noticed was it's a very
very informal economy the state sector
is very weak
a lot of improvising that goes on if you
want to buy a piece of bread you have to
improvise for the price
that kind of improvisation gets
congeals in a way into the architecture
and actually shipping containers of all
things are a huge part of the
architecture there's restaurants and
shipping containers there are people
baking bread and shipping containers
workshops are made out of shipping
containers so you can imagine that this
is the kind of architecture that's
appropriate to a place whose existence
is quite precarious where there is and
where people don't pay taxes where a lot
of things are open to negotiation
when the war on terror began
of course the cia was was the leader in
afghanistan it wasn't initially the
department of defense cia were the first
people in it and people that were
directing a lot of the activities
initially they had teamed up with the
group of people that we call the
northern alliance group of commanders
warlords whatever you want to call these
guys who provided the bulk of the
boots on the ground as it were for this
invasion of afghanistan and as the cia
and this group of commanders began
moving across the country predictably
enough they began collecting prisoners
and the prisoners then
they used shipping containers to
construct ad hoc prisons for them
there's a collection of shipping
containers at bagram air base where high
value prisoners were held and the
warlords had their own shipping
containers where they held the lower
value guys
shipping containers got a bad name a few
months later and the reason for that is
that the shipping containers that the
warlords were holding prisoners in they
started shooting them people started
suffocating
inside them while they're being
transported they started getting getting
massacred very very bad shipping
containers got a bad name and so the cia
said well we have to come up with
something that's a little bit more of a
permanent solution to
to this problem of what to do with these
high value
detainees one of the solutions that they
came up with was a facility that has the
code name the salt pit which is
northeast of kabul about 15 miles or so
in the very kind of a remote area
there's some brick factories around
there and in fact the salt pit
is in an abandoned brick factory
this
brick factory that was born on the
uh
battlefields of the war on terror
eventually became
probably the first black site cia had
set up this prison as what they call a
host nation facility meaning they had
afghan guards and afghans were
ostensibly in control the reasoning
behind that was that if anybody were to
die or to be tortured the cia would be
able to
um deny that they were responsible and
pin the blame on the the host country in
fact this did happen someone did die of
hypothermia
at the salt pit and there was an
internal investigation by the cia that
indeed found the american
leader of the salt outfit not culpable
for it
but this salt pit then became useful as
the war on terror expanded beyond
afghanistan the cia started bringing
people from other places around the
world to it this sketch here is from a
man named khalid al-masri who was
abducted in macedonia in and taken to
afghanistan where he was held for uh
five months
this is a drawing that he drew of
what he believed the inside of the
prison to be he didn't know exactly
where it was
but he described about a 10-minute plane
ride from
the
kabul airport to the place
we took his drawing and compared it to
satellite maps that we had of the kabul
area and found this building
and in fact we're able to go there and
we're able to go to this salt pit and
we're able to confirm that indeed there
were lots of americans at this
abandoned brick factory outside of kabul
people who are held in the salt pit
tell horrible stories as you can imagine
this is essentially a dungeon people are
not let outside they're giving
filthy water to drink they're constantly
interrogated by people wearing black
costumes and black ski masks there one
of the things that khaled al-masri was
told is that you're in afghanistan now
and we can do whatever we want nobody
knows that you're here
as this war on terror spread across the
world
this idea of these black sites also
spread across the world think of these
as the kind of evil twin to guantanamo
bay guantanamo bay was even though it
was in cuba and it was outside the law
it was still visible in a certain way um
people knew that it existed people are
upset that it existed but the idea
behind the black sites was that nobody
would know that they existed nobody knew
would know where they are people would
just disappear there
one of the first
real significant high value guys that
the cia picked up was this guy a guy
named abu zubaydah
and they shipped him to a
newly formed black site in thailand
and they began torturing him they were
perhaps worried that there was some kind
of imminent attack but they began
waterboarding him beating him up
asking
him to tell them what sorts of things al
qaeda was going doing it turns out abu
zubaydah was insane he was schizophrenic
but the cia wanted to get information
out of him
around the time that zubaida was being
interrogated and being tortured we start
to see headlines like this in the united
states these very vague threats against
shopping centers and apartment buildings
and that sort of thing
what was going on behind the scenes is
that zubaida was being tortured and he
was just going along with any suggestion
at this point that his interrogators
made and all of these um
admissions that he had made under
torture were making their way into the
headlines
another guy that had been picked up was
uh taken to egypt and under torture he
also
began saying all sorts of outlandish
things one of which made it into colin
powell's presentation to the u.n
colin powell famously linked saddam
hussein to al-qaeda terrorists with uh
this chart and in the middle of this
chart you see this uh ghost detainee
this detained al qaeda operative this is
this man al libby who has been tortured
in egypt and again began to confess to
whatever his interrogators asked him to
one of which was this connection between
saddam hussein and al qaeda
after the cia had been torturing these
guys they got very nervous about what
they had done
and so they went back to the justice
department to get retroactive legal
authorization
for the torture that they had inflicted
upon these various men they went again
back to this same crowd of people and
this is where the torture memos
famously come from that were written
in august of 2002.
more prisons spread
around the world another one uh popped
up in afghanistan that former prisoners
began calling the dark prison and they
consistently describe a prison where
there's pitch black there's absolute
darkness inside this prison i can't see
your hand in front of your face
they blast music 24 hours a day they
play eminem and dr dre and at some point
they were playing halloween sounds
and
the sounds of explosions and jets flying
by all sorts of crazy crazy things for
months at a time and they would hang the
prisoners up in this dark prison from a
steel pole across the top of the
the ceiling of the cells for for days at
a time
these black sites began
spreading all across the world probably
to places like poland romania
morocco people are being held in egypt
there's a whole network of prisons that
pop up around the world some of which
are directly controlled by um the cia
and some of which are these host nation
facilities that will be ostensibly run
by egyptians for example but where the
cia can ask these guys guys being held
there whatever they want
and so that brings us back to
afghanistan and in the same way that
rural north carolina is the perfect
place to fly
a mission out of if you're the cia
because it's kind of the middle of
nowhere it's not like flying out of
oakland where if you're flying
interesting planes out of there all the
time
people might notice and if they get a
whiff that you uh might be the cia
flying around the world to torture
people they might blockade the place and
have crazy protests
uh you wanna do that out of a place like
north carolina where it's gonna be lower
profile in the same way afghanistan
is the perfect place
to take prisoners because what you don't
really realize until you get there on
the ground is
there's not a national government there
there's a bunch of different governments
there and really the sort of power
breaks down like this there's the afghan
government there's the afghan army
there's the afghan police
there's the united states military
there's the european-based uh military
forces
and then there's the private military
contractors and the intelligence
agencies
and so what you start seeing there is
sort of
this sort of hodgepodge of power and
this sort of overlapping power
there and the sort of
generalized chaos that the country's in
makes it a perfect place to drag people
to
also what you start figuring out there
is that
who's doing
the torturing who's doing the grabbing
of people who's doing the interrogating
starts to get kind of blurry and and
kind of uh strange
so the
the slide that you're looking at
this is probably
a dyncorp
facility dyncorp is a us-based private
military uh contractor
and
we were speaking to uh afghan
journalists and they said oh we keep
hearing we keep uh hearing reports
that this particular facility the one in
the photo
is a secret prison that the americans
are using that they're taking people to
but we can't get in there and no one we
know can get in there so we went and we
visited um the police chief who has the
police station down the street from here
and we said hey what is that weird
facility up the street and he said oh i
think it's a secret american prison but
they won't let me in there either and
they won't let american soldiers in
there either it's kind of weird he said
to only let a few american special
americans get in there
um and we said
really and he's like yeah
so we went up the street to check these
guys out
and our translator asked um the afghan
guard what was going on there and he
said
oh this is a
u.s counterterrorism center and counter
narcotics center
we then asked the guys in the white
tower who had the guns pointed at us
what was going on there and they were
nepalese gurkhas and they said uh
you need to talk to the other guys next
batch of guys came out were bosnians
in uh
half military and half civilian clothes
so like camo pants and t-shirts with big
guns and we were like hey so what's
going on here and they're like oh we
can't talk to you uh you gotta talk to
the next guy so the next guy came out
and he was a very very muscular very
large american who was clearly
ex-special forces um i mean you know
like the rule is like you have to have
oakley uh glasses and big muscles and a
big gun and uh we were like hey so
what's going on here and he's like oh i
can't tell you that either no one can
tell you i don't know why these guys
said i could um but eventually we found
out that uh it's probably a facility for
this private military contractor there's
private military contractors crawling
all over afghanistan and whether the
rumors that you hear from the
journalists
and others that afghan citizens are
getting dragged to this facility or not
uh whether those are true it's not clear
but what is true
is when we took a trip
out of kabul to gardez which is south of
kabul which is a fairly dangerous place
to go the governor
of the province was uh blown up not that
long ago and his funeral was suicide
bomb the next day
uh we went to interview people who had
been definitely held by u s forces
and these men had been held by u s
military forces
and we wanted to talk to them about what
had happened and whether they had been
held with any of the
victims of extraordinary rendition if
they had any insights into that
and the stories that they told us were
fascinating and they were also
completely stomach-wrenching and
horrifying
they proceeded to tell us about
basically being
tortured
in ways that were just like abu ghraib
and
that were chilling in the detail and the
stories that they told us
were very similar like all the people we
spoke to and the human rights workers
that we spoke to all told us very
similar things that's what made us feel
like it was pretty credible
um so they would talk to us about
okay i was a suspected taliban
and one day the us military came with
the translator
and they grabbed me and they started
beating me and they cuffed me
and they took me to a us military
facility a detention center and they
beat me there and they stripped me and i
was naked
and
i wasn't fed for several days and then i
was beaten some more and then eventually
i was taken to bagram air base which is
the big u.s military base in afghanistan
and when i was there i was
interrogated relentlessly
forced to assume uh stress positions
which are the sort of very obviously
uncomfortable positions like standing
like you're being crucified for an hour
straight or bending over in an
uncomfortable way
and if i couldn't hold those positions
then i would be beaten some more
and
german shepherds were put on me
you know all these sort of things like
this i was barred from speaking i was
barred um
from
communicating with anybody
my sleep was disrupted constantly for a
year
these sort of stories i was left out in
extreme cold
i was left in a building where it was
where the roof had collapsed and it was
snowing and snow was falling on me and i
had no clothes on these kind of things
um
and so we heard these stories over and
over again
and
we asked so were you with any other
people who had been grabbed in other
countries and some of these men said who
were able who are who uh had managed to
talk to other prisoners said yeah we
were with people who were apparently
grabbed in other countries and
apparently had been held
probably by um the cia before they were
dumped into military custody
but here again things were kind of
blurry because these men described being
beaten
and and dragged around by uniformed
american soldiers but they also
described being interrogated over and
over again by men and women in civilian
clothing and they weren't sure whether
these per people
were intelligence with the military or
whether they were central intelligence
or who they were
so the things that sort of start
blurring and the whole
outline of the rendition program starts
blurring and becoming more complicated
than it's oh it's just this cia
phenomenon uh and that was one of the
things that we learned there the other
thing that we learned when we were there
is
the president
recently in september admitted okay well
we have people in secret prisons i'm
finally gonna admit it yeah we have
these black sites
but when you're in afghanistan you
realize that there's
20 different detention centers run by
the military uh that are acknowledged by
the u.s in afghanistan and they're all
basically secret facilities they're all
black sites here's why
the afghan government can't get into
these facilities
the human rights monitors can't get into
these facilities
journalists can't get into these
facilities
and most americans have no idea that
they even exist let alone what's going
on inside them the only way that we know
about what's going on in them is that
men have been dragged there wrongly and
after a year or two
eventually have gotten out and they've
gotten out with papers from the us
military that say they were there so
we're pretty sure they were in fact
there and they were abused but otherwise
these facilities are just as secret in a
lot of ways as the cia facilities so
that was that was an interesting
revelation for us
so the the i think the point that we're
trying to make is that we went into this
project thinking about the extraordinary
rendition program and trying to focus
very specifically on that and i think
that by the end of it we had realized
that this kind of informality this kind
of extreme violence this kind of holding
people outside of the law and
disappearing people had really become a
paradigm for what the us has been doing
more generally this is most obvious of
course with the kinds of things that
were happening at abu ghraib with people
being held as ghost prisoners there
so the cia paradigm that's very informal
in the shadows kind of warfare
that has has become the real
paradigm for what what the us has been
doing across the world
we always have to
improvise a conclusion when we get to
this point in the talk depending on what
the news has been for the last week but
i think
i think that we would conclude today by
kind of invoking the cliche that
when
when you torture someone it's not only
the person who's been tortured that gets
affected by that it's the person who is
doing the torturing
who gets affected by that as well and i
think that we might generalize that
to the united states right now the fact
of the matter is the united states been
disappearing people holding people in
secret prisons torturing them
what was the response to it well the
response to it was the military
commissions act very recently which in a
sense legalizes all of this
what's very very disturbing about that
is that all of these programs were begun
as something that was deliberately
outside of the law that's why it's
covert action right if it were legal you
would it wouldn't need to be covert
action
what's happened recently is that in fact
these extraordinary circumstances these
extraordinary programs have been built
into the core mission of what the
government does they're no longer
over i mean they're still secret
but they have become
an established part
of what we do
and
that
on that grim note
maybe we can
take questions
and uh when you if you want to ask a
question make sure to speak into a
microphone i think there's probably
somebody around here who can
provide one
[Applause]
um wilson big was on
channel 29 two nights ago he was in
bagram for a couple of years and he said
he
that they
killed two people right in front of him
so
not only do we disappear people we
murder them it's part of our
state sponsored whatever i would like to
know how do you think the u.s whether it
was the cia or whoever got all these
other countries like egypt
took or poland or romania or whomever to
cooperate so quickly and so thoroughly
and so secretly you bottom off
on the most on the most basic level we
know that that part of this program
after 9 11 immediately was to buy off
lots and lots of intelligence services
now in the case of egypt the cia has
been working with the egyptian
government for a very long time the
egyptian government's been fighting
against uh islamic radicals for a very
long time and have a very deep and
collaborative relationship with um the
united states
so a lot of these are our pre-existing
relationships but you can but this thing
with poland or romania i mean it sounds
absurd uh
when you think about it at first why
would someone like poland or romania
collaborate with a program like this and
you think about it a little bit longer
and it starts to make sense if you're
poland what kind of diplomatic relations
do you want to have with the u.s if
you're romania what kind of diplomatic
relations do you want to have with the
us
doing the us a favor like this might be
very much
in the interest of a country like that
you know i actually think that asking
why other countries are going along with
the us is the wrong question to ask i
think actually the question to ask is
why are american citizens going on along
with what their government is doing i
mean this has been in the washington
post it's been in the new yorker it's
been in the new york times the chicago
tribune 60 minutes and so sort of the
question to ask i think more is
europeans don't like this they've been
absolutely outraged about this there's
been all kinds of investigations there's
cia agents who are facing criminal
charges in europe for kidnapping people
so
they're not really trying to go along
with it as
as much as they were i think now we ask
the question is why is this not even an
issue in the united states
uh yes uh why do you
think that uh the u.s government uh
believes this is an effective program
you know i don't know why you know i
can't answer for for the government why
they think it's an effective program and
why
what the rationale is i mean for us this
was a reverse engineering of the process
and sort of trying to break it down
um from the outside as people who didn't
have intelligence sources going into it
um i think though that when you're on
the ground you start seeing something
in afghanistan it's very interesting
and human rights experts and people who
are afghanistan hands would tell us like
look from what we see part of grabbing
people and holding them
and treating them very badly is about
telegraphing a message
to other people out there as much as
it's about extracting information from
them it's also about letting other
people know that if you mess the united
states something seriously seriously
medieval bad is going to happen to you
and that's that's one of the operating
theories that i have
well i can answer that by paraphrasing a
guy named mike shoyer who was a former
head of the bin laden unit at the cia
who actually is the architect of this
rendition program or one of the one of
the main architects of it he's spoken
quite a lot
about it recently and he says that the
reason for the program at this program
began began under clinton i mean it's
been around for much longer than just
this war on terror um it changed with
the war on terror but it's been around
much longer and he said the basic idea
was get people off the street he said uh
international law was too clunky u.s
courts were too clunky
the administration put a lot of pressure
on the cia to do something with guys
that they expected uh suspected of being
terrorists and gave the cia no direction
as to what to do with them and according
to mike sawyer this is the
beginning
of that rendition program now again
during the 1990s when this was going on
it's my understanding that each one of
these renditions had to be specifically
signed off by the president there was
there was much more oversight but
nevertheless this was a a
an institutional institutional capacity
that was developed and so after
9 11 when uh kopher black famously said
that the gloves had come off
um it seems like the gloves were taken
off of this program and it became much
more generalized and
much more of a
core
tool
that's their rationality
well when adam mentioned
that question where is the sense of
outrage in the part of the american
people what's interesting is you have
this human rights or civil rights lawyer
alan dershowitz openly and repeatedly
calling for justifying torture and
changing international law you have the
the just attorney general arthur
gonzalez you have mentioned john yu
who's right here in berkeley and i know
they have some
occasionally some vigils or protests
but uh there's no really outrage
large-scale outrage one might expect
because this is being done in our name
and it's not secret anymore
you know and that that's that's totally
true we were speaking last night and i
said you know one of the interesting
things about right now is that
everyone's very interested in these
mid-term elections and everyone's saying
oh well the democrats perhaps they'll uh
retake congress and that would be
a significant thing and to me what's
most significant is that no one's
talking about this on the campaign trail
you have
you know really what's the most profound
step backwards as far as human rights go
that we've seen in easily a generation
and we have massive erosion of civil
liberties here at home as well and we
have with the military commissions act
sort of the possibility you sort of see
these two things melding
where we have torture coming home and
the possibility
uh
that u.s nationals will start getting
dragged into completely lawless uh
quasi-legal processes and no one wants
to talk about it no one's particularly
interested in it and no one's making an
issue and that's that's very interesting
to me
do you work with the european uh union
together the parliament has a big
investigation on that and you mentioned
one i think it's a german guy who was
caught in bosnia who what was a big news
story in germany in the last couple of
months so we talked too so is there
perhaps you can talk a little bit
because it was interesting also that the
german government who was officially
against the iraq war and in the back
doors they kind of supporting all the
story what's going on so perhaps you can
talk about this a little bit
um like ac mentioned there have been uh
huge investigations into this
in europe uh the people in charge of
those uh investigations were not granted
subpoena powers so they had to
do what um
anyone else might be able to i mean they
had a little bit of authority but they
didn't have subpoena power to conduct
these investigations what they found was
that indeed it seems very clear that a
number of european governments were
working with the united states uh
berlusconi government in italy uh the
german government through some
unclear
whether to what extent the german
secret service may have been involved in
this uh of course the um
tony blair's government
uh
numerous uh
probably the irish government on
on some level in the in this in the
sense that they would um allow these
flights to pass through irish airports
quite regularly
but
yeah there have been huge investigations
into this in in europe and a lot of
people are
outraged and in fact a number of cia
agents have been indicted
in europe for kidnapping
what role
does the
flourishing
heroin trade coming out of
afghanistan have to do with all this
well you know there is there's an
interesting tie-in and and like
and this is one thing that people were
speaking to us about over there is that
you know the u.s recently
extradited and indicted uh an afghan
national for
alleged um involvement in the opium
trade there and and we thought that was
fascinating because the us has no
extradition treaty
with afghanistan so
you really can't grab someone and bring
them over here for criminal trial in the
same way that you can't grab someone and
take them to a dungeon somewhere to be
tortured there's there's no law allowing
you to do that and it's also kind of
interestingly symbolic that
opium is the biggest industry in the
entire country it's the biggest business
in the entire country and so the
government's idea of
making a symbolic arrest is they'll
arrest one person and charge them i mean
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous it's also um
interesting to note that if you were at
this point to unplug the opium economy
overnight that the country would descend
immediately into complete chaos so i'm
not really sure that anyone wants to do
that
you sort of mentioned passing that some
of these people were picked up and
had nothing to do can you talk a little
bit more about some of those cases and
sort of the impact on
opinion in europe and in the middle east
well you know for you know the the
poster
um dude for all this is hollad el masri
and he was the german citizen of
lebanese descent who
goes on vacation and it turns out to be
a real crappy vacation because he gets
grabbed by the cia
and he's
whisked off to um
afghanistan and eventually five months
later
kicked out uh
of a car on a hillside in albania a semi
lawless spot and
makes his way back to germany to find
that his his wife and children have fled
the country thinking that he'd abandoned
them and it was really like it's a
cliche to invoke kafka moments like this
but i don't really know what else you do
but say that's pretty kafka ask
and um i think his story his story
because he got out and he was willing to
talk and he was back in germany where um
western media had a lot of access to him
he was really the person i think that
has shed more light on this and gotten
more people talking about it and
distressed about it
than anyone else you know now in
afghanistan
there have been
uh and afghanistan iraq there's been
thousands of people
jailed
and many many of those people released
uh and these are people who've been
jailed by u.s military forces
um probably interrogated by intelligence
and military forces
and then eventually
uh the military decides oh we don't
really need these guys they're not
really al-qaeda dudes they're not really
insurgents they're not really taliban so
let's let them go back to their life of
being a goat veterinarian or being a
small um shopkeeper and
when you're in afghanistan at least you
get the distinct sense uh
that people are very unhappy with the
way their friends and neighbors and they
have been treated by the us
and uh they don't
really appreciate people getting dragged
into to american dungeons for months or
years at a time
uh for not having done anything
you know and a lot of people we spoke to
have been very pro-american
uh until this happened to them and then
they were very very angry with the
united states unsurprisingly and they
talk about losing everything that they
own they talk about losing their jobs
they talk about
you know feeling like their reputation
had been dismerged because they'd been
arrested and been accused of being a
taliban supporter
uh or an al-qaeda guy and so yeah it's
not really feeding a lot of good
feelings for the united states at this
moment
in regards to your question i want to
add that there's a little bit of a way
that language breaks down in regards to
this and what i mean by that
is that there are a number of people who
have been in these prisons who have
gotten out for uh hallelujah
and the news story is always that
someone got out and they were completely
innocent this happened to someone they
were completely innocent
well
that's not entirely true what's it
what's true is that these questions of
innocence and guilt these are legal
terms the whole point of this system is
that you're keeping people outside of
any legal framework and so the the the
this way of thinking that i think we're
used to thinking about criminality and
terrorism and this sort of thing
i think we should not uh we should
hesitate
before we try to think about it in those
terms because we are
we make in in
in my opinion some very uh
dangerous
premises mentally when we start to think
about oh whether people are guilty or
innocent when we're talking about people
who've been disappeared and tortured no
and and that for us
um that really came home when we met
with mullah zaif and he had been uh one
of the top taliban
leaders he was very very high in the
taliban he was uh unquestionably not a
particularly nice person
and he was you know right off the bat
completely insulting to our translator
because he wasn't dressed in
sufficiently religious garb so we didn't
find the mullet to be a particularly
great guy you know it's not somebody
that we'd want to party with you know
but then we also you know talking to him
and he was not
a victim of rendition but he was in
guantanamo bay again basically outside
of any kind of legal framework he was in
the hull of a ship for a while yeah i
mean
he was he was in pretty uh pretty not
very um
fun dungeon-like conditions and pretty
much outside of what any of us would
consider to be rule of law or sort of
the the rules of any society and you
know even speaking to a guy like that
you realize this is not somebody that i
particularly like this is not somebody
that i think should um
necessarily be running a society
but i also don't think that they should
be subjected to this kind of treatment
and that's really where it comes down
you know with somebody like that
um
i i've heard
as a theory that
guantanamo is holding these people
all this length of time
um and they're bringing in different
groups of interrogators so they have
this kind of uh
this wheel of you know these people
coming in and then going out and there's
some more people coming in and going out
and and i heard that and there was the
idea that this was being used as a
training
uh
place for interrogation processes and i
was wondering if that if you'd heard
anything about that and if there's some
relationship between the school of the
americas and everything that went on in
south america and argentina
and this present set up with the cia
prisons if you heard anything about that
um i think the book to read about that
is is a book called a question of
torture by a guy named alfred mccoy and
he argues that
a lot of the kinds of things that we're
seeing happening now really have very
old routes going back to the post-war
era things like the phoenix program in
vietnam things like school of the
americas and he argues that a lot of
these
capacities that are being used directly
by americans now have been uh developed
over long periods of
of time by the us
and that in in a certain way a lot of
this is is really nothing new
so
what does seem to be new
is the willingness the openness of the
us administration to endorse it it's
interesting a year ago in november there
was an ad the new york times a full page
ad we showed a picture of a man with a
blindfold and it said torture is not an
american value and i expected to see the
aclu at the bottom of the sand instead
it was former secretaries of state state
department people including people like
thomas pickering who had been involved
in torture in vietnam and el salvador
you know warren redmond madeleine
albright
what was interesting
is that
this group was seeing at the present
administration was blowing the cover
because the u.s in fact has been
torturing and doing all these things but
before it was under the table and now
cheney rumsfeld uh bush and all their
cronies are saying it's okay for us to
do that and i think it's an important
distinction to make and that's why
it's causing a rift between the estello
line establishment represented by bush's
father and and younger bush
you know and that's interesting because
it took us a minute to pick up on it but
that was really a master stroke of um
politics when bush came out and said
yeah we have been keeping these people
in uh secret detention he didn't say
we've been torturing them but you could
read that into that and he played it
very well he said we have a small number
of people and we've got 14 of them and
he mentioned names and the names that he
mentioned uh you know several of them
are definitely
people you would suspect had done some
pretty heinous things
and he said and now we're uh if we pass
this military commission's act we're
going to send them to guantanamo and
they're going to be uh tried and
adjudicated and it was a brilliant
brilliant play because what it meant was
no one could say okay these guys are
bringing up um you know the evidence is
there's good evidence guys like khalid
sheikh mohammed these are you guys that
no serious person thinks are good guys
let's put it that way no they're
probably people who are very very mired
in serious terrorism no one's gonna say
okay don't adjudicate them don't bring
them to justice don't try them in some
way
but his play was this if you want them
tried then you have to basically sign
this law you have to you have to approve
this law
you have to embrace it and the law is
going to retroactively basically
make anything that's happened to them
okay
and and that was just kind of genius
um you mentioned an opening about an
airfield in nevada
well i'm just wondering why rendition
airfield in nevada what are there secret
prisons within the united states um i
don't think that there are secret
prisons in the united states in a
certain way that defeats the
point of having a secret prison but
what probably was going on there and and
we we don't i don't think anybody knows
what really happened
in uh late 2002 in nevada but probably
there was some kind of counter terrorist
exercise at the nevada test site
involving
potentially nuclear materials or
something like that that would be the
best guess and this is this is territory
that's used by the intelligence agencies
it's used by
you know the air force is used by all
different kinds of people who are deep
into military and spook
world
still this plane operations are still
running i mean those companies who you
mentioned you find out they're still
working
yeah some of them are
some of them have changed i mean they
they change these things around
constantly
um but yeah they're they're
flying every day
um earlier you mentioned about the
containers well
in november of 2001 after the battle of
conduce uh
like 8 000 taliban was shipped from
mazira sharif and condos over to
shebaran
prison but there was only room for 4 000
although they had like 8 000 prisoners
and they left
american soldiers guarding this whole
enterprise
left 4 000 prisoners in those containers
and they shot as you said into the
containers to get let air into the
containers but they shot in to the body
of the containers not into the top so
blood started like pouring out finally
after four days they opened the
containers and most of the men were dead
but they were also like pakistanis and
and uh chechnya's people from all over
the place
anyway so they buried them
alive and dead
supervised by american soldiers in the
desert and then later they even moved
those bodies those skeletons
and i guess you're familiar with the two
the
uh
uh afghan massacre uh film that those
two irish brothers uh made of this whole
inter but you know what the americans
got away with it
it just like
disappeared it was huge at the time yeah
there's been a lot of that you know
there's been a lot of getting away and
even seymour hersch's book about a chain
of command skips over that they talk
about the pakistanis in the mid in the
mid midnight flights pulling the
pakistanis out of chevron but not a word
about what happened to
um
the
all those people buried alive
under the aegis of the american military
it was my understanding that uh general
dostum had perpetrated that massacre and
i i haven't seen people say whether they
were americans present when the massacre
happened or not i didn't
um this canadian guy who was kidnapped
in the new york airport
that's the one piece of information they
got through to me now i wonder do you
think that piece is going to disappear
you haven't mentioned it
is the is the is
that his name yeah he said well you've
got a bit of press but oh he's been
getting tremendous press recently
because the canadian government came out
and said okay you're innocent well do
you think that's going to disappear to
that story or do you think that might
start getting more play in getting this
into people's consciousness
i think it's been it's gotten a huge
amount of play in in canada and around
the world i'm just i think it's gotten a
lot less play
in the u.s but uh for example khalid
al-masri everybody knows who he is in
germany everybody in canada knows who
maher aurora is and people are very very
upset
about it so i don't think that there's
any kind of
there were some attempts to cover up
these stories a few years ago but i
don't think that that's what's going on
now
i saw a film not too long ago about the
venice florida where there were
flight schools where the supposed um
terrorists who ran who did 911 train
and uh it was very interesting that town
was like a cia town it was full of cia
retired cia people and the the school
where the guy was supposed to learn to
fly was operated by a guy who seemed to
be funded by the cia did in your
investigation have you picked up
anything about this 911 thing that that
from the side or anything no no okay
all right
what was the biggest obstacles or legal
obstacles you encountered during the
process
the legal obstacle during which your the
process uh writing this book and
attending the documents that are that
are printed in your book
you mean did we where did we encounter
any options right right
well
not really because we just
again like we said before one of the
there's this contradiction in the way
that the cia is set up is that it's a
lot of it is done through civilian front
companies so anybody can get
this documentation this is these are not
secret documents and there's very good
reasons why they're not secret documents
um
so not in that sense at all
you know but
you know beside you know for our thing
you know basically following corporate
paper trails and trying to paste pieces
together and starting there and figuring
out anything we could figure out along
the way using different sorts of sources
of information like the plane spotting
logs and um the faa records and these
sort of things
um that would that was how we worked but
the biggest uh
the biggest challenge was that beyond
those sort of basic sources is that
everything was secret yeah everything's
secret and a lot of people that you try
to talk to get angry with you and
there's a lot of people that won't talk
to you and
um so those are huge obstacles like we
went to
the homes of many pilots who were flying
these missions and like let's just say
that the vast majority of them
definitely did not want to speak to us
and they were not happy to see us
you know like two guys show up on your
doorstep and say hey um we want to speak
to you about the war on terrorism we
hear you're a pilot uh you know
that that's a challenge like people a
lot of times don't really want to talk
about what they're doing for the cia
maybe just one more question
are these the same pilots that flew the
iran contra the stuff
the drugs from all from through
illipango
in the 80s
into all kinds of military and civilian
airports into this country in mina
airport in arkansas
we don't know if they're exactly the
same people but it's the same structure
the same way of doing it yeah
so uh maybe
we can just talk informally
okay one more question
tell us more about those guys who the
spotters they just sit there and like
put down um
record the numbers of the
the plane
serial numbers as they fly in and out
well this is this is a hobby in
mostly in europe not so much in the us
um but there was a number
once you figured out the tail numbers of
these different aircraft you could look
on these european plane spotting
websites and there would be tons and
tons of pictures of these things all
over the place
um the people that we talked to
were a little bit unusual in the sense
that they had
they were like a very very advanced
version of this and what they were doing
was using
data feeds that were coming directly
from the federal aviation administration
we were talking to guys who are air
traffic controllers that were able to
see a lot of things
that
someone off the street wouldn't be able
to see for example so i'm tracking
youtube spy planes with homemade radar
with one of these guys so the so the
guys that we that were
useful
for the purposes of figuring some of
this stuff out we're not exactly the
people at airports writing down um
tail numbers but people doing a very
very advanced version of that
are you in danger since you do such an
overt operation you go barging into
people's
offices and ask them outright no it's
the same as going to the mall and if
you're like being the mall manager what
they're doing they probably wouldn't be
happy to see you either
thank you very much for having us
[Applause]
so
um
for more information on torture taxi on
the trail of the cia's rendition flights
visit co-author trevor paglin's website
at paglin.com
[Music]